hallelujah indeed you know pretty put
together trailer for a movie that
i've heard apparently doesn't exist so
among fandom we have a trailer for zack
snyder's justice league i feel like it's
going to be a short video because this
trailer had one point
one purpose which it did fulfill and
that was to show us
that there was a completely different
movie that was planned different than
the one we saw
different than justice league so bring
on a rendition of hallelujah and let's
see the clips
and generally the clips are like hey you
didn't see this did you you didn't see
that did you you didn't see this [ __ ]
did you yeah
that's different isn't it tell me again
my movie doesn't [ __ ] exist but we
see black suit superman there are even
scenes where i was like oh that is the
same scene oh no
that's different though yeah you see
some new scenes new contacts
steppenwolf looks completely different
his armor looks like it's living tech or
something it's all rippling way better
than that [ __ ] that we all forgot
about
although i will say spoilers what did he
dies you just heard joe morton get
vaporized in the trailer
[ __ ] i guess even the aspect ratio is
different than the justice league
rocking that 4x3 aspect ratio i imagine
this just for the trailer but we do live
in a world where there's
a black and white version of logan
there's a noir logan so be careful
with that [ __ ] snyder you have me
wanting a 4x3 aspect ratio version
of justice league when it comes out on
vhs don't make a man want like that i
don't know why i want that
that's it's inferior in every way i
won't lie in my nerd room i have a vcr
hooked up to one of my crts and i
got the vhs's to go along with them why
cause i mean we get a glimpse of dark
side in this trailer which i'll be
honest i was like
i'm missing his armor a bit but i mean
it's one shot it's one
shot it's not a scene it's one shot in
this trailer that's all you get of dark
side so who knows i'm not going to break
down like we usually did this
differently with dark side from one
shot so i'm sure darkseid's gonna be
savage besides like the guy who voiced
darkseid
did you see that clip on the internet
where he kind of like he did a voice
in this audio clip which sounds like it
could be dark side people were like whoa
was he giving a hint about darkseid and
he sounded awesome so it looks like all
the nightmares that bruce wayne was
having this shit's about to come true
and again hallelujah what is it with
zack snyder giving that link between
someone getting [ __ ] and hallelujah
night owl and silk specter [ __ ]
zack snyder and his justice league get
[ __ ]
[Music]
at least in the context of this it's it
getting unfucked there's that
yeah the trailer did its job zack snyder
giving us all right yeah hallelujah it's
coming out also hallelujah for
possibly the reasons i listed but
probably
more likely that hallelujah it's coming
out it might be great it might suck but
i'm just glad
he has the opportunity to give us his
symphony though i will say this fast
forward
40 years from now when zack snyder's
justice league is generally
speaking seen as the justice league that
happened and people start telling their
kids about that movie that we called the
justice league in which superman had a
cgi
face and kids are like what what did it
really yeah the cgi is terrible if i
could find a copy
i would show you but i can't because
everyone got rid of their copies and
it's super rare
point is in the world of hard copy
collecting that's how [ __ ] becomes
valuable so hold on to your justice
league copies i'm just saying i've seen
this [ __ ] happen before
i mean not exactly like this but and ben
affleck is back as
batman now i guess bat fleck is he's
back
not just in this movie but he's gonna be
in the flash movie although with
monologues like this
i don't care how many demons he's fought
and how many hells
he's never fought us not us united
there's zero doubt as to why also the
batman versus superman
warehouse throwdown scene that scene was
always awesome anyhow solid trailer
great look i know we've all heard that
the movie is going to be different
different in scenes scenarios footage
context but it's another thing to see it
now we've
seen a glimpse into that alright so the
first trailer for zack snyder's justice
league have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you